as I was preparing for this session
today I realized that I'm gonna be in
the uncomfortable position of basically
mispronouncing my own name to a bunch of
Dutch people I've been getting this
question all day long I am half dutch my
father was born here but I'm Canadian I
grew up there
so my name is Peter mark bear ward which
is how we pronounce it over in Canada I
know I'm mispronouncing it I'm on the
solution architecture team here at
Google cloud and what I usually do and
what I spend a lot of my time with is
helping customers migrate to the cloud
where they're coming from data centers
other private clouds and so on and what
we end up spending a lot of time on is
actually data in databases it's always
kind of topic concern with a lot of
customers and what that actually ends up
meaning is that I talked about cloud
spanner a great deal one more thing I
know I'm the very last session before
cocktail hour so I'm gonna try to be as
efficient as possible with my time
especially considering our small delay I
don't want to be the only thing between
a group of people and some drinks so off
we go and so what I'm gonna try to cover
today is a brief history of spanner why
it was created what was the motivation
at Google what is cloud spanner as it
has been released today how does it work
how does it compare to other things and
then finally a brief demo that we better
get to considering all the work that
went into it so what is better exists
and to get to that you really have to go
back to about 2005 at the time pretty
much every dollar that Google generated
was based off of Adwords and AdWords was
backed by a manually charted my sequel
database and that database was charted
on customer keys or customer IDs rather
and as we grew we had to reach our that
database and we had to restart it a lot
because we were growing really quickly
and the restarts were getting
increasingly painful to the point where
the last one actually took several years
literally to complete at that point we
said you know this is untenable we can't
continue this way there has to be
something better
and so something better led to
essentially the development of spanner
and so what we were planning out what
eventually became spanner we had to sort
through what our requirements were and
essentially at that time those were what
were AdWords requirements and so there
were three big ones first it had to be a
horizontally scalable database this was
the problem we were encountering already
with my sequel we had to solve for that
and so we needed something that could
scale with us we had gone from a 10
million dollar a year company to over a
billion dollars a year in such a short
time and we knew the scale wasn't ending
it was only going to be more and more
and so we had to be horizontally
scalable second we had to have asset
transactions we were dealing with money
budgets customers partners agencies we
had to be sure that any transaction that
got written to the database was a strong
transaction we couldn't deal with
eventual consistency we couldn't accept
data loss we had to have acid
transactions in consistency and then
finally we couldn't afford downtime
AdWords was the thing that was driving
Google all of Google at the time so
every minute every second that AdWords
was down meant lost revenue to Google
and so downtime was unacceptable for any
system that we were creating to replace
the existing one so we had to have
uptime and so if you look at these three
requirements and think about what was
available at the time there was really
nothing that could fit those
requirements in the market until cloud
spanner and so that brings us to what
cloud spanner is and if you could play
the video now please
we demand a lot of our databases and our
databases demand a lot of us they're
fragile expensive and tough to maintain
when things break it can be hard to put
the pieces back together at the speed of
your business and you often lose data in
the process we've all come to expect the
distributed databases can't be globally
consistent and scalable but what if you
didn't have to make trade-offs what if
you could have a fully managed database
service that's consistent scales
horizontally across data centers and
speak sequel this is cloud spanner a
mission-critical relational database
service built from the ground up and
battle-tested at Google for strong
consistency and high availability at
global scale at Google we use spanner
for services that billions of people
access every day it's the only cloud
service designed to be a massively
distributed relational database with
transactions and sequel semantics and
we're talking massive spanner can scale
up to millions of machines across
hundreds of data centers and trillions
of database rows stretching across the
globe while behaving like it's all in
one place where you want it we've built
cloud spanner to be fully managed and
secured automatic sharding and
synchronous replication with low latency
and schema updates without downtime
means your data is highly available and
reliable consent of endless provisioning
and worrying about maintenance you can
focus on growing your business no matter
your needs you don't have to hit a wall
with your database service get started
with cloud spanner and build what's next
all right so I'm just here to introduce
that video thank you very much everyone
goodbye kidding so that's kind of just
an overview of what cloud spanner does
and when you dive into it what is kind
of cloud spanner and how does that
relate to what spanner was as an
internal product so first of all spanner
is a fully managed database service
which means that you don't have to worry
about upgrades patching security keeping
it online or anything like that that's
all done by our own site reliability
engineering team that make sure that
spanner is up 24-7 as you may imagine we
got fairly pedantic at Google actually
about a number of things but one of them
is about what does consistency mean what
does global consistency mean and for us
it means external serialize ability and
that's a highest standard for what
global consistency means and there's a
lot of kind of discussion inside the
industry about eventual consistency vers
global and what really that is versus
what's acceptable for us we had to set
the highest bar possible for what our
needs were and spanner meets that bar
and so that means that you get asset
transactions across many rows you have
relational semantics you've got DD LS
that you can create tables you can do
inserts updates deletes queries using
sequel in effect you can use the same
sequel that's already available across
Google cloud platform for bigquery so
ANSI sequel 2011 with some extensions is
the same sequel that you use in bigquery
that you can also use on cloud platform
we also have automated synchronous
replication as of today so we have
regional spanner so you can create
regional instances of spanner and those
are within a single region spread across
many zones and that gives you four nines
of availability and
so when you write to spanner no matter
where you're writing it within the
region you know that write is accepted
and committed and later this year we
will be rolling out multi-regional
spanner which actually gives you a
higher level of availability that gives
you five nines of availability which is
about two seconds of downtime per month
and so that's gonna be coming later this
year and finally we've been using this
internally at Google for nearly 10 years
this is battle-tested this has been run
on production systems for a long time
and the reason I can kind of get up here
and make these claims about consistency
about availability is because we've been
doing this for so long we've got the
data we've got the history to know that
we can stand by these claims in fact in
addition to AdWords which has been using
spanner since it went into production
there are a lot of other systems at
Google that use spanner as well so the
Play Store uses spanner Google cloud
platform in fact also use a spanner the
data plane that maintains all the VMS
across cloud platform actually runs on
top of spanner so I kind of just said a
lot of things about how it works and
sort of ways it doesn't work but in a
more concrete sense what does that kind
of mean so I think it's useful to
compare it to both relational databases
and no sequel databases which is where
we often get the most questions so if
you compare it to a relational database
spanner has sequel spanner does schema
updates it has strong consistency and
where the comparison gets interesting is
we often get questions like well how
does spanner compare to my our DBMS you
know my C blowpro stress whatever it is
and that's a sometimes can be an apples
and oranges comparison because when you
talk about an our DBMS you're usually
talking about a single node system where
where all the reads and writes are going
through a single note a particular note
and spanner is a distributed system and
so with a single note system like that
if you've got any issues like you know
unexpected downtime like unexpected
failure of a node you have to do
security patches you have to do an
upgrade you have downtime with that
system you can create alternative
strategies where you have things like
master master slaves or reach slaves
where you failover and those alleviate
the downtime but there is still downtime
that is incurred and with spanner again
part of our design requirements was that
we couldn't have downtime and so there
there was that kind of there's that kind
of change and that difference there and
so basically the strategy for for
spanner becomes it's a it's a horizontal
strategy for scaling I mean while with a
single node database you've grabbed his
vertical scaling you got to say you know
I need a bigger box anymore Ram I need
more memory more disk what-have-you
I hope the provider I have has a bigger
VM because we're hitting the limits on
our database with spanner that that
issues gone it doesn't have that problem
anymore now the other thing you can do
to scale relational database is add read
replicas and so you alleviate that load
on top of a master database on top of
the master node you spread the reads out
to the read replicas you increase your
capacity of the master node but then you
have to deal with replication lag and so
if you have to be sure you have to be
positive that what you're reading is the
most consistent view you can go back to
the master to get the most consistent
view but then you're consuming the
resources that you had set aside for
writes and so that's a situation that
just doesn't happen with spanner and on
the other hand with non-relational
databases we often see the situation
where we go to customers kind of large
and small across the board where we see
a very familiar pattern an application
is created it has a relational database
on the backend the application grows for
whatever reason becomes very popular it
starts storing a lot of data and so on
at a certain point the relational
database is replaced by a no sequel
database
Kassandra MongoDB whatever it is and
when that decision happens it is usually
done by saying our top priority in this
change is horizontal scalability so
we're willing to sacrifice consistency
if we can get that scalability and so
that trade-off is made and then you
start pushing all this logic that once
existed by the nature of the database
into the application so you're starting
to create consistency within an
application which is introducing more
complexity more maintenance more bugs
for the sake of gaining horizontal
scalability and with spanner you don't
have to make that trade-off you can
continue to scale horizontally but you
still have consistency you still have
acid transactions one of the things we
get asked a lot about is what was the
hardest part of bringing spanner from an
internal product to a cloud product and
I think what one of the things that we
worked hardest on was making it open so
Google is very much about being an open
cloud and meeting you where you are with
the tools that you already use and so we
tried to inject this across the board
into cloud spanner so the first thing we
started with was using standard sequel
like I said earlier this is the same
sequel dialect that is spoken by
bigquery right now a couple years ago we
looked at our products we said we were
kind of honestly we were kind of all
over the map with sequel standardization
so we decided to standardize ANSI sequel
2011 extensions and that is currently
used by bigquery and now it's also used
by spanner and so we wanted to make sure
we standardized that and made it a
familiar language for anyone who's
making that transition second we had we
spend a lot of time on enterprise
features so at launch spanner launched
back in March when it launched it
launched with the most I think features
of any of our new products had ever
launched with things like encryption
identity access management logging all
these sorts of things that any kind of
standard enterprise would be interested
in and be required to use a database in
production and spanner launched with
those on day one
a third was to make spanner and
appealing target for developers we want
to be a developer friendly platform and
in order to do that we really think
there there are two kind of essential
things one you have to have great
documentation in two you have to have
good libraries and so for the
documentation spanner was actually in
early access for over 12 months so we
have an early access program with some
customers and that was it was there for
over a year and among the many things
that we did with our early access
customers was actually refine our
documentation they told us where the
holes were where the gaps were things
didn't make sense things weren't
explained well enough and we iterated
over and over and over on that
documentation and it really helped a lot
to be able to make the documentation at
launch really first-class alongside that
prabha that process was developing
client libraries so we really want to
launch with a wide variety of popular
platforms or a popular languages I
should say with with our libraries and
so we launched with Java and Python and
node and go and those are really
first-class libraries what we've done
with those is try to make it as easy as
possible for developers who are familiar
with those languages to get started and
start using spanner in a way that's
familiar in a way that is natural in
that language we've abstracted away a
lot of kind of the subtle intricacies of
connecting to spanner of using the API
in a way that makes sense for each
particular language and then finally we
launched with a JDBC driver so we knew
it was important for spanner to be able
to connect to existing tools especially
existing BI tools and so we launched
with a JDBC write a driver that's
read-only and so what that means is you
can connect your spanner instance to
tools that you already use that you
already have and to be able to read the
data off of there and so that's kind of
thing that you could do for customers
whether they're internal or external if
they want to read the data if they want
to connect to the data if they want to
build reporting off that data that is
something they can do with that JDBC
driver so the type of workloads that we
expect most customers to use with
spanner mostly fall into these four
categories and this is something that we
saw in the early access and something
that we've seen
since spanner has launched and the first
is transactional and this isn't really
surprising at all it is a relational
database it has strong transactional
requirements storing transactional
capabilities I should say and so we see
a lot of transactional use cases which
is not surprising if you've got a use
case where you're selling something you
can't sell more than you actually
possess or you want to record
transactions you want to record
financial transactions spanner is a
great use case for that and we saw this
happening a lot especially in those
cases where companies had in order to
maintain a certain size or a certain
scale they had built in a lot of
consistency logic into an application
database or into an application rather
than the database and spanner being able
to take on that that logic from the
application and being able to lighten
the load on development and bug
maintenance second scale out so we often
find ourselves kind of trying to answer
the question of do I have to have a
minimum data set size to use spanner
does it have to be you know hundreds of
terabytes so I can really efficiently
use it absolutely not you can start
using spanner and start getting a really
good use case out of spanner
even if very like small like say single
digit gigabyte size databases because
part of the advantage of spanner is not
just storage the the advantage here is
that you're gaining this availability
and you're gaining the consistency of
that availability spread across a region
and so if you've got some kind of
mission critical database if you've got
something that you have absolutely have
to have the highest level of
availability possible if you've got
something that you know cannot go down
if at all possible
and it's got to be relational it's got
to be stored reliably spanner is a great
use case and this is something that you
know we see a lot of customers using
where they really relied on the
availability rather than the size and
the scale in order to use for their
applications third and this is a very
very common use case at Google as a
global data plane if you've got a user
base let's say you've got a global user
base you've got users
and the states you've got users in
Europe you've got users in Asia and they
all log into the same application but
your sharding along the geographic user
database so you keep a database in each
one of those three regions and those
users are home there when a user logs in
you've got to figure out how to send
them to the right home so even if your
home dinh the right place how do you
know where that person's home is and so
you've got to have some sort of metadata
base to be able to describe where to go
and that's solved by putting that
database somewhere and two groups of
people live with with bad latency and so
you can solve that by using spanner as
an actual global database where you get
much lower latency to to read and then
finally database consolidation so where
this has been really useful is if you
think of say a system where you need to
do some analytics and you've got your
customer transactions in a my sequel
database you've got analytics sitting in
a data warehouse and you're pulling in
log files from storage and you want to
bring them all into a single place and
you will run analytics on top of that
you put them in reports where you've got
data basically in a lot of different
places and you've got to bring it
together for a single source of truth
before you can start doing reporting
spanner can actually replace all of that
so spanner can be that source of truth
it can be that location where everything
goes anyway and you run reporting on top
of that and so we saw that happen a
great deal too so after talking about
spanner in the abstract how does this
thing actually work so it's pretty easy
to create a spanner instance I'm going
to walk through that shortly when you
create an instance you're basically
telling the spanner service what do you
want your replication topology to look
like you create a node you create
multiple nodes however many nodes within
this particular reason you region and
you select that region and then each of
those nodes has replicas across the
region and so all this data is getting
replicas
automatically across the region a few
limits an instance an instance of cloud
spanner can have up to 100 databases
within it and each database can have
2,000 tables but within each table you
can have an unlimited number of rows the
notes themselves do have a limit for
storage and QPS so what happens when you
try to do an update what happens when
you try to write something to your
spanner instance what happens is it
comes into the cluster and spanner in
some sort of magical way determines
who's the owner of this particular data
it is replicated across each zone but
each particular node or within spanner
there are particular nodes that own
chunks of data they are the primary
writer of this data and the rest of them
are replicas and so spanner again more
or less by magic determines who that
owner is and sends it to that owner and
they write it we use a custom paxos
algorithm that allows us to do consensus
based writing that is not not all voters
need to agree it just need a majority
and that gives us our global consistency
that gives us an ability to quickly do
writes but still be consistent there are
times when we will do two-phase commit
especially if you're going across nodes
if the owners if there's more than one
owner of the data that you're writing
but we try to avoid that because our
Paxos algorithm actually writes the data
faster but we want to do whatever we can
to ensure that we have global
consistency so
how does that actually work in terms of
actually using it if we consider a kind
of normal relational database use case
let's think about these two tables
together and so you have a singers table
and you've got an album table in a
regular relational database you build
out each table you make a primary key of
singer ID primary key album ID and then
if you wanted albums to be a child table
you make that a composite key or you
make it a foreign key and so you've got
some foreign key constraints on top of
that as magical or at least I believe
it's magical as magical as spanner
sounds it can't do everything
identically there have to be trade-offs
with how it works and the trade-offs are
in particular with how tables relate to
each other and how tables depend on each
other and so to do this in posts in
Postgres in spanner we do something
slightly different
we actually interleave the tables
together and this is essentially telling
spanner this is data that I commonly
query together this is data I commonly
update together please leave them in the
same data location and so that is what
interleaving table does from a
conceptual point of view this is the
same thing as two related table with a
parent-child relationship and you set it
up the same way so you set up the artist
table with you know artists ID artist
name and then in an album table with
album ID album name and then but then
you tell spanner instead of saying
create a foreign key I'm going to
interleave this table with the previous
one and I would like to or if not if you
don't want to inject a dependency on
this so if you delete one I want you to
delete the child relationships
so what does it actually look like if
you're familiar with sequel it should
look pretty familiar actually this is
actually valid DDL syntax for spanner so
creating the singers table is pretty
straightforward I think that would run
on most databases albums again pretty
straightforward and the real difference
here is that you want to interleave
seeing singers onto this database and
it's so it's going to know that singer
ID is that primary key from the
interleaving parent table and you've
made album ID the primary key as well
and so one thing that's really neat
about spanner and it's very different I
think from relational databases in a
good way is that you can make table
changes without taking your database
offline you can make table changes live
and there is no interruption in your
service or performance and so let's say
that we wanted to add an age to our
singers table then we just alter the
table and everyone continues and that's
now part of that table definition and
whoever's reading it writing it will
start using it right away
which is pretty cool actually and so how
does this actually look in code like I
said we've got support for Go Java
Python nodejs right now this is Python
code in case you're not familiar I'm not
really a Python guy I'm more Java but
somebody was kind enough to write this
up for me so I'm not going to really
complain too much but the process is
relatively similar everywhere you could
go to the command line install this
library from pip - pip install Google
Cloud library and then in your Python
file import the spanner library
instantiate a client you'd say client I
would like an instance ID from spanner
and then with that instance ID you're
gonna grab your handle to your instance
and then once you grab the handle to the
incidence you say alright I would like
you to return me a handle to database of
whatever name so I can get a handle on
that database and then you can start
executing sequel and this right here
this execute sequel statement is just a
regular sequel query
as long as it's an SI sequel 2011 it's
gonna be fine and so you can just
execute sequel queries right there which
is for a lot of use cases going to be
very similar to what a lot of existing
code already does so a couple of things
that I want to touch on before I get to
the demo is how does spanner fit into
the existing portfolio of cloud products
I admit that this can get confusing
and/or daunting at times especially if
you're not familiar with how they all
work and so we do try to kind of spell
out where we think the best
recommendations are for each of these
products so if we want to start on shoot
back we want to start on this side with
cloud sequel so cloud sequel is managed
my sequel and Postgres and so if you've
got say a web framework that relies on
my sequel like say like Django or
WordPress or what-have-you that's a
really good use case if you've got a
small data set if you don't have high
availability requirements where you can
afford some measure of downtime my
sequel is a good fit there if you've got
a no sequel document store use case a
this is a lot of web frameworks a lot of
websites use this cloud datastore is
really kind of a good option for that
because cloud datastore is shared
resources you start by paying nothing
and then you pay as you use and so you
can really grow with datastore probably
the most well-known example of data
store is snapchat so snapchat started
out real small they've gotten very big
and they've been using datastore that
whole time so you can really go from
very very small to very very large on
datastore on the other hand BigTable is
BigTable is more of an analytics
database very very high speed low
latency like single digit like single
digit millisecond response times for
like time series data for financial
analyst analysis for IOT analysis
BigTable is really
particularly well-suited for that and
then finally over here is bigquery so
bigquery is a cloud enterprise data
warehouse it is for large-scale
analytics reporting really the the kind
of endpoint for data so so that it's and
can be in a place that can be analyzed
long term and so we're spanner fits into
all of this is spanner is good for
mission-critical databases that require
high availability regional access and
then later on this year when we release
multi-region it'll be for these this
global of data plain use case that is
kind of not well-suited for the rest of
these applications and then the slide
you guys got a sneak peek at we do ya
understand despite those explanations
sometimes it can kind of be hard to
figure out where where does my
particular use case lie and so we kind
of we came up with this flow chart it's
not 100% perfect but it does help a
great deal by making some kind of broad
assumptions and broad decisions and so
the decision tree basically goes your
first decision is this structure if it's
not structured it really should go into
object storage so that's cloud storage
if you're using or if you need to store
unstructured data from a mobile platform
then what you can use is the firebase
SDK to get to firebase storage which is
backed by cloud storage on the other
hand so it is structured if you have an
analytics workload what you really need
to investigate is it something that's
going to require updates is going to
require changes in low latency in which
case that's more of a BigTable use case
if not then that's bigquery and then
going down the main branch again if it
is non relational data then datastore is
a good use case if you're not using a
mobile platform and again if you're
using a mobile platform firebase
real-time DB is a great solution for non
relational database or data and then
finally if you do have relational data
the decision comes down to do you need
that horizontal scalability do you need
that higher availability
in that case the answer is spanner if
not then cloud sequel works pretty well
finally before the the demo
you've probably heard in a couple of
sessions today that partner integrations
are very important to us we want to make
sure that partners that you're working
with software that you're working with
works with our new and existing products
and so launching with a lot of partners
was really important to us and we
launched with X plenty zoom data a
looker and we're working with a kind of
pretty much anyone you're working with
or using we are working to make sure
that they can that are shared customers
will be able to take advantage of all
the things that we create together and
so if we do support it today I hope
you're using it and taking advantage of
it if we're not it's something we're
actively working on alright so with that
we're gonna try this demo
cool it works alright so if you're going
to start with spanner if you were
curious about how it goes I really
really strongly recommend looking at the
documentation we really did spend a lot
of time on this a lot of iterations and
it is very very extensive so it goes
from concepts to quite a few how-to
guides diving into each of the tutorials
for each of the library's API reference
resources all sorts of stuff it's really
actually very very deep and extremely
well done so I strongly recommend
checking out the the documentation so
now what I'm going to do and in my own
cloud console is I'm actually going to
create a spanner instance and it's
bookmarked because spanner is awesome
and I'm gonna show you just kind of how
quickly this can be done so oh let's
call this next it's gonna autofill that
we're going to select Europe because
that's where we're sitting and let's say
ten nodes I think is enough for here and
I'll show you how much it cost per hour
it has some guidance around what kind of
capacity the each of these nodes are
capable of and kind of what you're
signing up for and we're gonna create
that and let's see oh dear it took like
three seconds what are they doing so
anyway this is actually live this is not
some sort of nicety that the console
does for you this is actually a live
status of your cluster as or instance
rather as soon as you create it so this
is up and running so those ten notes are
now mine but all you've done is kind of
create a spanner for lack of a better
term and this is not the same kind of
thing is essentially a container of
databases you haven't created any
database is nothing to query nothing to
insert so you've got to go ahead and
create a database and so why don't we
replicate the example from earlier we're
gonna create a small music database and
I'm just going to create these in the
console these are all options that you
could do from
from the command line and from there we
go from any of the libraries and so I'm
just doing this because obviously it's a
little easier oh I artists that's not
the primary key there we go
so artist ID
this keyboard is not an English keyboard
so we're going to require that we're
going to add let's say artist name and
we'll make that a string oh I did it
again
there okay and will require the name as
well will continue will make the artists
ID the primary key and away we go and so
now what we're gonna do is actually add
that the interleave tile table so we'll
call this album and we're gonna inter
leave this we're gonna inter leave it
with artists it's the only choice but
you could have a drop down of whatever
tables you have in this database we're
also going to say cascade on delete so
delete parent-child rows together and so
in this case we inherit artists ID
automatically because we've already told
spanner that it's going to be
interleaved and I'm gonna make an album
ID required and we're gonna make a album
name and we're gonna make that a string
and say it's also required done continue
and again because it we're inheriting
this as an interleaved table part of the
primary key is already the parent
primary key and it's requiring a
composite key so we're gonna select
album ID as the second part of the
composite key and we're done and so now
we can go ahead and create our database
and in a couple seconds yep
we have tables with columns that we can
start reading and writing from but as I
sit here and think about it I really
think we should edit albums because when
you're looking at albums you probably
want to look at a release date that
seems pretty important so why don't we
add release date
and make that a date type yes we're
going to require that too done save and
we've updated our database and we
haven't told it to go offline we haven't
had a maintenance window we just kind of
continued along as as before this is a
pretty neat feature of the console and
that you can look at the equivalent DDL
for any of the tables and in fact the
entire database
has the same feature so if we go up here
we'll see the DDL for this database and
that's available to you kind of at any
point another feature that we have is
for the database you can look at the
monitoring on that database as you're
using it so CPU operations per second
throughput and so on this is on every
single database and in fact for the
instance itself also has that same
monitoring enabled right away so you can
look at note count and some similar
features and you know now that we've
been using this for a little bit I
realize I'm massively over provisioned
so I think 10 nodes is way too much why
don't we go down to five and save that
and our spanner instance has continued
again without downtime again without end
users being affected at all because
apparently we were over provisioned and
so everything continues just fine so now
what I'm going to do is go into a
different spanner databases created by
one of my colleagues conveniently called
Europe spanner demo instance and this
has quite a bit more data in it so at
least we can do some queries here and so
this database is backing essentially a
ticket a ticketing application think
like Ticketmaster or something like that
where you have artists who go on tours
to different venues which have certain
number of tickets and ticket categories
and users who come in and purchase
tickets it's been a certain amount of
money and so they need accounts and they
need financial information so a
relatively classic kind of relational
database use case this is something that
you really need strong transactions when
people buy tickets for concerts they
probably expect those to actually happen
so if we look at this database again
we've got a few indexes on some tables
we've got some interleaved tables some
children tables in places that you may
imagine we're using about 600 gigs so
let's do a query and let's take
advantage of writing things down so I'm
going to take this query and what we're
looking for is events in the Netherlands
at venues that have a significant
percentage of unsold tickets so you
could imagine making this query and
saying well you know these couple of
venues for these events don't have you
know are largely unsold let's do a
marketing event let's do a special
something like that so let's run a query
on what's available here and we've got
two venues that have nine thousand six
hundred and sixty four seats available
and that's the total number of seats so
it looks like there is zero sold on that
first one and the second one same story
so they are not doing well whatever this
event is it's not very popular and with
every query that you make is through the
console you can actually look at the
explained plan and you can look at kind
of what happened
what's the optimizer do how did spanner
go through the query and read your data
and find your data and so you can dive
into that we previously looked at this
and said you know there's probably an
optimization we can make here to make
this a little bit better we took about
three quarters of a second to run the
query and scanned nearly fifteen
thousand rows so what we're going to do
is actually this is one of the features
that we have in the sequel spec is being
able to force an index on the query and
so we're going to force an index on
oh dear I've lost it where's demo2 dear
we're gonna force it on here
so this is the syntax
I think event date
so here we go we're gonna try this on
the fly and see if it runs no it didn't
nope
this is why you write things down nope
all right I'm terribly sorry
so if that'd work basically what you can
do is modify your query by looking at
the explained plan and something I
strongly recommend I also strongly
recommend writing things down in the
right places I do apologize for that
that's not what I meant to do but it
does give you a lot of versatility and a
lot of tooling enabled to enable you to
actually analyze your query so if you're
having queries that are running in ways
that you don't expect if you think
they're taking too long if you think
they're not working or returning the
right number of rows do look at the
explained plan do look at what spanner
is actually doing when you execute that
query and you can really actually get
quite a bit out of that it might be
things like force index it might be
things like interleaving different
tables it might be things like adding
indexes to tables so do look at that
there is a lot of information there in
order to help you along and to to kind
of improve how you interact with spanner
but on that note that's it and I'll be
happy to take any Q&A thank you
[Applause]
yeah if you have any questions could use
are there microphones around oh yeah
could you use a microphone please yep
question Oh yep is there a hibernate
dialect for our clansmen already
is there a what die like a hibernate for
Java your java developer oh I'm sorry no
I don't believe so next question right
here
I have simple questions first is does
the spanner do back backups or something
like this I didn't solve this it's
something that the spanner team is
working on right now it is not something
that exists in the product today okay
the second question you said that
spanner don't do meet downtime so how do
spanner
make our indexing of protein text when
there are a lot of updates on our DMS
you have to index the index because it's
too large so data it has do you do
spanner Nitra index or it would run
automatically no I'm not sure I got your
whole question but we don't do automatic
indexes you can create indexes on tables
no sorry what I'm asking Qin so another
another way does this panel to vacuum
out out of vacuum oh okay like like like
garbage collection and cleaning up rows
and stuff like that yes yes it does also
we've indexed I believe so but I'm not a
hundred percent sure on that one okay
yeah thanks
any other questions yep right there
get it I'm sorry is it exam work sorry
this is better yeah yeah really close to
the mic please sorry and Google pending
on therefore open sourcing um sorry what
I was sourcing the good spinner
technology open sourcing spanner as a
technology I don't believe that is part
of the plan right now yeah I don't think
so so that means no on premise
insulation Zephyr well I mean we do have
a lot of white papers that describe how
spanner actually works so it's
theoretically possible and in fact
actually I can't remember the name
somebody has actually created an
open-source hmm cockroach thank you yes
is an open-source version of spanner
that's based off the spanner paper but
that was not released by us any other
questions
one more here
hi thank you for the presentation very
interesting the question is about so
this like globally scalable but at the
same time transactional database right
how do we deal with the looks of the
tables or records etc and does it affect
the users experience globally we don't
lock tables or rows you can go into more
detail in the the paper which will
explain it better than I can but loosely
speaking it is based off of timestamps
so we are pretty we have an extensive
timestamp system it's mostly based on
satellites and atomic clocks in the data
centers so we have as precise as we
possibly can with an acknowledged amount
of drift time stamps for every single
transaction and they are reconciled by a
master in a regional Rhett and a
regional set up there's a somebody who's
in charge and we we elect leaders on a
relatively regular basis that is in
charge of deciding what is what came
before and what came after and so we
have ordered transactions that way and
so you expand that to the global to a
global set up and it kind of functions
the same sort of way but it's mostly
based off of that you can get a lot more
and probably better detail from the
white papers in fact actually as part of
the the documentation website there are
links to all the white papers that have
to do with spanner so the original
spanner paper that came out about ten
years ago they didn't update one this
year and there was one that was written
by Eric Brewer to specifically discuss
how spanner handles the cap theorem
which actually goes into a lot of what
you just discussed about how to
reconcile when which transaction wins
when they come in and it a lot of it has
to do with being having really good time
stamps but then also acknowledging that
nothing's perfect okay one small
question sure it is only cloud solution
yeah we cannot use it as a on promises
unless you want to use cockroach No
thank you yeah any other questions
cool cocktail hour thank you very much
everyone
[Applause]